what's going on there reject nation no john coming
in today so it's just am wah but i'm the one who
rewatched all the stranger things uh just a couple
of months ago a little fresh in the noggin i hope
and today we got ourselves a clip stranger things
for official clip 11's powers if you guys can
leave a like that would be very much appreciated
also please subscribe and click that notification
bell reason why is because well on may 26th we
watched top gun gotta shoot edit that review
and then at midnight that night two episodes there
will be one come out the same night obi-wan comes
out all the stranger things four comes out at
least part one of stranger things four releases so
it's gonna be a lot to cover just in that weekend
alone and some of you guys might not know this but
the way we handle things behind the scenes here
usually one episode of television if it's an hour
long takes roughly four and a half to six hours
to make them fully complete to be visible here
on youtube that's why clicking that notification
bell is going to be the best reward you can do
to make sure you get notified when our video is
up that's how it works all right let's do this
goddamn bullies
the new [__]
what the hell was that
oh
oh no as sad of a clip as that is i cannot wait
for this season man what's neat about watching
this clip is in stranger things season one mike
dustin and lucas sometimes i gotta count them
on my fingers because i'm like am i getting the
names wrong with mike lucas and dustin they were
getting bullied severely in that first season then
eventually 11 stepped in and became like their
their protector of sorts and really stood up for
them and it was really cool to have her in their
corner and then now to see in this season where
it's picking up where eleven still does not have
her powers after the cliffhanger of season three
how she's just going to school being like a normal
girl and now having to go through the experiences
of what those three and will included is just will
wasn't in you know a large part of season one
because he was stuck in the upside down the four
boys had to endure and now she's gonna be going
through it herself i'm wondering if it's gonna
be like repetitive or really explore something
different here and i imagine it'll be different
just due to the fact that 11 so much of her
character has been like identity soul-searching
like who is she when she's not stuck in the
rainbow room who is she not under the the power
hold of dr brenner as she's slowly been uncovering
her identity and finding herself being completely
stripped of her powers is in this position where
how can she find this other version of strength
and endurance while dealing with things that a lot
of children deal with in high school i think it's
going to be a really fascinating season to explore
because i keep trying to pick up on like what
might the themes be of season four because when
i rewatch seasons one through three it was cool
watching them all back to back like not taking a
break because like in season one so much of that
is inflicting trauma you know dealing with the
anxieties of loss you know like you had hopper and
joyce and you know hopper had lost his kid that's
something i totally forgot about honestly the
whole storyline with sarah it's already watching
it and so hopper had lost his kid and then joyce
dealing with the the fears and paranoias and
how it's taken a toll on the city so everyone's
being inflicted with this trauma and dealing with
so much unknown and then season two dealt with so
much with post-traumatic stress disorder season
three was all about you know learning to let
go and move forward i imagine that they're all
eventually gonna be going back to hawkins here
but seeing it being brought back to this element
of bullying would and this is not the final season
because usually in like a movie format you know
you you circle back to the beginning in a lot of
ways so this isn't the final season but something
about just this one scene alone feels indicative
of the first season and watching 11 go through the
experience that the boys had to deal with i wonder
like what she will discover about herself how
she'll learn to display strength without you know
freaking killing people or snapping their necks
or some [__] but at the same time i am hoping
that stranger things four will give us some type
of cathartic release where she does get her powers
back uh i mean it seems inevitable at some point
11 will get her powers back i'll be very surprised
if she doesn't so i wonder if like at some point
she will bully this they say her name was angela
ashley i forget i could play it back i'm not going
to this specific you know mean girls bully the the
rachel mcadams character if 11 will come back
and you know do some type of bullying [__]
not kill her but you know make her piss her pants
or some [__] i don't know and then it makes me
wonder too like will has also been just such a
lost soul a big part of season three with will
you know after being stuck in the upside down and
dealing with his own trauma he just did not know
how to move forward you know he was clinging
on so much to what the past used to be like
now that he's with 11 there's two folds here
that i'm really excited for a the type of lost
identity soul-searching there's a lot of things
like thematically about 11 and will that feel
so complementary towards one another and so i'm
excited to see them have scenes with each other
what kind of bonding will they have well they end
up being a little bit more brother and sister like
especially now that 11's living with them what
will become of their relationship and what will
eleven's experiences of being bullied due to will
specifically it's like she can probably confide in
him will will learn to stand up to the bullies you
know for her as well like it's funny that it took
four seasons for them to seemingly have you know
a lot of scenes together because these two uh in
a lot of ways have been you know the biggest
outcasts of of the ensemble other than like
jonathan for these two of the same age range like
being these targeted bullies who deal with like
the worst case of trauma all the time feeling far
from normal or feeling far from the average kid
i'm looking forward to like what kind of you know
empathetic relationship they deal with one another
and really i'm hoping that they see a school
counselor this season because i feel like they
need it with all the crap they've been through man
i'll throw us out there too i know a lot of people
weren't big fans of that episode in season two
they felt like a backdoor pilot i think the the
character was eight i think though that to to wrap
up the story especially with eleven i do think it
would be a bit of a necessity to bring her back
i would like to see that story resolve maybe in
season five maybe they won't do it this season but
i'm hoping that at some point eight does actually
come back into the series because everything that
eleven's experiencing here goes in conjunction
with a lot of the reasons why eight was trying
to pull 11 into her specific modern day world
last thing i'll say you know i hear that
this season's gonna be dealing a lot with
horror gonna be more horrific than the other ones
it is interesting knowing what eleven's powers are
knowing how much stephen king inspiration there
is in this show one of the horror films i grew up
on a lot was the movie carrie and i am sort of
getting carry vibes but the reason why i don't
fully go there is only because of the fact that
carrie you know like murders everyone in high
school and i don't think they're gonna put 11 down
that dark of a path but regardless i do like the
idea that it still plays on that nostalgia factor
that i i think that duffer brothers handle so well
but anyway guys thank you so much for being
here what did you think about this clip for
stranger things four i'm very much excited for it
i feel like this is gonna be an epic ass season
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click the notification bell leave a like
eric horstmann you messaged me the
other day i hear you're in some recovery
sorry to hear that try to try giving you a call
i would really like you to call me back eric
get it joyce i miss you i have been thinking
about you a lot i was just telling olivia the
other day if [__] gets really bad must take a
trip to atlanta that's what's gonna get me to go
to atlanta is if your life is in danger that's
the only way i'm gonna go to atlanta but no i
feel like you're gonna be okay in the end just
know you're in my thoughts significantly you
don't strike me as an individual who believes
in god so i won't say you're in my thoughts
and prayers but here are my thoughts at least i
really miss you man and you mean the world to me
i hope you you give me a call back before
this video goes live cause um i need you to
approve this shout out because i i feel like
i might have already said a little too much